- ♪ THREE ALIENS
CAME FROM THE SKY ♪
♪ THE GALACTIC COUNCIL
SENT THEM ♪
all: ♪ AND HERE'S
THE REASON WHY ♪
- ♪ THE MISSION IS TO STUDY
EARTH'S MOST AVERAGE GU-UY ♪
- AH!
all: ♪ TO SEE IF HUMANS
♪ ARE WORTH SAVING
OR IF EVERYONE HAS TO DIE ♪
- WAIT, WHAT?
I SEE.
UH-HUH.
[phone beep]
[sobbing]
- LOOKS LIKE SOMEONE'S GOT
A CASE OF "THE FROWNSIES."
- IT'S NOT "THE FROWNSIES,"
OKAY?
MY MOM WAS JUST DIAGNOSED
WITH TERMINAL CANCER!
- OH, WE CAN CURE THAT,
NO PROBLEM.
FOR US, THAT'S LIKE
THE SNIFFLES.
- REALLY?
- YOU'RE IN LUCK,
BECAUSE OUR ALIEN SEMEN...
- UH-HUH.
- HAS THESE SPECIAL ENZYMES
IN IT, AND THEY'LL
FIX YOUR MOM RIGHT UP.
- OH, GOD.
OKAY, WELL, WHAT DO WE DO?
W-WE PUT IT IN A PILL,
OR SOMETHING?
- GOSH, YOU'RE BAD
AT GUESSING, JEFF.
- SO--[coughs]
HOW EXACTLY DOES THIS WORK?
- OKAY, THIS IS--THIS
IS GONNA SOUND INSANE, MOM,
BUT, UH,
CHIEF WINDFEATHER HERE...
- HELLO.
- HE, UH, HAS SPECIAL POWERS.
YOU KNOW, LIKE BUFFALO SPIRIT,
AND STUFF LIKE THAT.
- UH-HUH.
- BUT REALLY,
TO USE THESE POWERS
TO THEIR FULL POTENTIAL,
HE HAS TO BE VERY,
VERY CLOSE TO YOU--
INSIDE OF YOU ACTUALLY,
AND, UH, YOU KNOW,
WHAT HE'S GONNA DO TO YOU,
IT'S GONNA SEEM A LOT LIKE SEX,
BUT IT'S NOT SEX AT ALL.
IT'S JUST
AN ANCIENT, ANCIENT THERAPY
THAT IS GUARANTEED TO WORK.
SO WHAT DO YOU SAY, MOM?
- WELL, IT COULDN'T BE WORSE
THAN CHEMO.
- [grunting]
- [whispering]
WHAT IS GOING ON IN THERE?
- HUH, THAT IS MORE STUBBORN
THAN I THOUGHT IT WAS GONNA BE,
I'LL BE HONEST.
- WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
- UH, HOW DO I, UH--
OH, A BOWLING BALL
HAS THREE HOLES IN IT, RIGHT?
- YES.
- OKAY,
SO IMAGINE HOW HARD IT WOULD BE
TO BOWL A GOOD GAME
WITH JUST ONE FINGER.
- WHAT'S YOUR POINT?
- I NEED MY OTHER TWO FINGERS
SO WE CAN GIVE HER
THE FULL TRIPLE-INJECTION
TREATMENT.
GUYS!
- [shuddering]
OH.
[all grunting]
- HMPH!
GUYS, THIS IS A MISTAKE.
I SHOULD'VE--
- GOOD NEWS, JEFF--
NO, GREAT NEWS!
- WE DID IT.
- [laughing] OH, THANK GOD!
THAT'S AMAZING!
- SHE'LL NEVER
GET CANKER SORES AGAIN!
- WHAT?
- IT'S FUNNY,
YOU GUYS THINK THEY'RE
SUCH A BIG DEAL. FOR US--
- SHE DIDN'T HAVE CANKER SORES,
YOU [bleep] IDIOTS!
SHE HAD CANCER! CAN-CER!
- [gasps]
- WELL, THE ONLY CURE FOR THAT
IS THE TRIPLE FIST.
- NO!
[all humming]
[ethereal vibration]
- OHH.
- WHOA.
- HONEY, IT'S ME.
HOW YOU FEELING?
- I FEEL AMAZING.
- WOW!
YOU GUYS ARE INCREDIBLE.
HEY, LISTEN,
I GOT A BUM HIP.
YOU THINK YOU COULD WORK SOME
OF YOUR MAGIC ON ME SOMETIME?